You often mentioned disciplining children,
so they behave.
What is your advice for making them
behave without resorting to corporal
punishment?
Well,
first of all,
it depends on what you mean
by corporal punishment.
Um,
timeout could be regarded
as corporal punishment.
It also depends very much
on the age of the child,
um,
at say a two year old,
well,
in my new book,
by the way,
I have a chapter in there called don't
let your children do anything that makes
you dislike them.
And the reason that I wrote a chapter
about that is because people who let their
children do things that make them
dislike them end up disliking them.
And because there's a
huge power differential,
generally speaking between
adults and children,
if you end up disliking your children
because they're not behaving well,
they're behaving disgracefully say,
or they're,
or they're challenging your position
in the authority hierarchy to regularly
something he won't put up with.
By the way,
even if you think you will,
it's necessary to get your
disciplinary routine straight.
So the first thing I would say
is figure out what the rules are.
There shouldn't be too many.
Um,
for two year olds basically
they have to know what no means.
And they also have to learn as
they approached three not to kick,
hit bite or steel essentially.
Now it's easy to train a two year old,
but no means you can actually start
with a child that's only 13 months old.
A child that can cry,
let's say that or that can crawl.
Let's say that you have a child is
starting to crawl and wants to explore the
house.
So the first thing you do if you have any
sense is try to get rid of most things
that the child could cause a
tremendous amount of trouble with,
uh,
to,
to the things or to the child
so that it's reasonably safe.
Um,
and then the child is going to want
to want to crawl around and get into
everything.
And so,
but maybe there are things you
don't want him or her to get into.
Like maybe there's a uh,
oh,
what would we say?
Maybe there's a tablecloth,
and on top of the
tablecloth there's a plant,
or maybe there's some plants on the
floor and when the child is crawling and
goes off to do something
that he or she shouldn't,
um,
you can just grab his leg and you know,
gently but firmly and say no.
And the child will keep trying to move
forward because they're stubborn little
gliders.
And you can continue to say no.
And if you persist with saying no,
then the child will eventually
give up and sort of go limp.
Now,
now and often the child
will cry when you do that.
And of course that might
make you feel guilty,
but what that means is that you've
effectively brought to behavior to a halt.
And if you do that 10 times,
you've got to watch your child and don't
stop them from exploring things that
they need to explore it.
You want to use this sort
of thing with judiciously.
You can grab them by the leg and say,
no,
no.
And wait until they give up.
Usually they'll cry and
then you can let them go.
And then soon after,
you do that about 10 times soon.
Then if you just say no
with the same tone of voice,
the child will generally,
what happens,
the child will immediately
cry and then stop.
And then after about 10 repeats of
no without having the leg grabbed,
then no,
we'll just produce
stopping of the behavior.
And that's unbelievably useful
because as soon as your,
you train your child to
understand what no means,
then they really have free reign of
the house in some sense with relative
minimal supervision from you.
First of all,
they can learn what things
they're not supposed to get into.
And it's amazing how fast children
can learn that and how fast they can
generalize to the class of things
that they shouldn't get into.
Like you don't have to teach
them every single thing.
They can generalize very rapidly.
That's not much different than thinking.
But also once they are capable
of understanding what no means,
you have an extremely potent means of
helping them regulate their behavior with
a minimum of intervention.
So that's unbelievably useful.
So now let's say you have a two year old
who's pretty contentious and two year
olds are pretty contentious.
Some of them in particular
because both 5% of two year olds,
most of them are male,
are quite aggressive by temperament.
And those are the ones that if you put
with other two year olds will frequently
kick hit bite or steel.
Not all kids are like that,
but some are,
and most of them get socialized out of
that by the time they're about four.
Now let's say you have an at two they
also start to experiment with saying no
back and also with misbehaving,
although they can do that
even younger than that.
So if you have a two year
old who's particularly
rambunctious and who decides he
isn't going to listen to you,
we use [inaudible] in this example
because it's boys that are more likely to
misbehave and not I not listen.
You can,
you can pick them up and you know by
the arms now you gotta get your attitude
right because you don't want to be stupid.
You don't want to let
your kid make you mad,
especially when they're really little
cause you're really big and you can hurt
them.
And so you gotta,
you gotta have a clue.
That's why you want to get the
rules of discipline in order.
The minimum rules of discipline and
why you want to have a strategy.
But let's say your two or two year old
is insisting upon doing something that
you don't want him to do,
like,
uh,
inserting a fork into an electrical
outlet and you just can't have that.
And so you can say no,
hopefully you've already done the
no training that I recommended.
And then if that doesn't work,
what I recommend doing is picking the
child up by the arms and then putting them
on the steps.
Say,
look,
you sit there until
you're ready to listen.
Now,
um,
are usually the child will sit there and
then the rule has to be something like
you can get up as soon as you're ready
to be a civilized human being again.
And you can refer to yourself,
your own attitude during
a process like that.
Because if the child does comply and sits
on the steps and then comes and says,
I'm ready to be good,
and you like them again,
you've got to be honest about this,
then you can tell that he's honest in
his decision to rejoin the civilized
world.
Now sometimes if you put a two year old
that's particularly rambunctious on the
staircase,
that as soon as you let go of their arms,
they'll run off.
And that can be a game or it
can just be an act of defiance.
And in that case then you go get him and
he put them back on the steps and you
do that several times if necessary.
And if that,
that becomes a game,
then you sit on the step and
you hold him by the arms.
Remember no anger cause he's just too,
for God's sake,
you know,
you don't have to be angry is put
them on the steps and hold up.
Say,
look,
I'm not letting you go until
you sit there and behave.
And so if you hold them for a while,
he'll squirm and look away and so forth.
But you can get a visit.
Tension.
If you're a little bit stubborn,
you hold them there and say you're going
to sit there until I decide that you
can leave.
And so you hold them and he'll squirm and,
but you can outwait them if your patient,
but you got to make the time and then
eventually he'll stop squirming and you
can let them go.
And then you can sit there and watch him.
And when you think he's decided that
he's going to be a civilized creature,
then you can say that's good and you can
give them a pat on the head and you can
say,
let's go back and do what we're doing.
And the rule has to be,
you see that the punishment not only has
to bring the behavior to a halt in the
most merciful manner possible,
but that's still effective.
But it also has to satisfy your need
for order and justice so that you don't
carry resentment and irritation about
the child's misbehavior forward with you
because you don't want a kid yourself
about what sort of Nice person you are.
You're not nearly as nice
a person as you think.
And no one likes to be,
um,
brought down the authority hierarchy
by a recalcitrant two year old.
So in almost all circumstances,
those processes will suffice.
Um,
there's other disciplinary strategies
that you can use to that are more
positive.
I mean,
one of the things that you can do,
for example,
if you're,
let's say you want to get
your child to go to bed,
which is a really good idea,
you should set a stable
bedtime for your child.
And I would say if they're under four,
it should be around eight or
seven or something like that.
Because you want to have a life and you
want to have a life with your wife so
that you don't end up hating your child.
And so one of the things you can do if
you want to train your child to go to bed
at eight,
so maybe he's not going to bed until
10 right now and you want to fix that.
So you say,
okay,
go to the grocery store or a little
convenience store and buy 10 little gifts.
And it can be cheap.
Kids don't care.
They're not very bright.
You know,
you could fool them so by 10 little
things that you think your kid would like
and wrap them up and then put them up
on a shelf where he can see them at,
can't get at them.
Then you say,
look kid,
I'm going to put you to bed
at nine 30 tonight and uh,
if you don't get out of bed then
I'm going to give you one of these.
I'm going to give you one of
these gifts in the morning.
So,
or if the,
or you can do it another way too.
If the child is always giving you a rough
time about getting ready for bed and
going to bed,
you can say,
look,
if you're,
if you put on your pajamas without
fussing and you climb into bed,
they'll give you one
of these little gifts.
And so then if that works,
then the child can have a little gift
and he's in bed at nine 30 and then you
can make it nine and then you can make
it eight 30 and then you can make it
eight and those are called,
that's called success of approximation,
right?
You hit the target,
you specify the target that you want
the child to achieve and then use small
rewards,
not too often in order
to attain that goal.
And those are unbelievably effective
strategies and they can actually be pretty
fun.
But I would say the advice to not let
your child do anything that makes you
dislike them is really,
really useful.
Um,
you want to talk this over
with your partner too,
so that you have your
disciplinary strategies and
your rules talked out so that
you don't work at cross
purposes to one another.
So,
okay,
so that's probably good enough for that.